how's your arm wonderful wouldn't feel
right to leave dawn without a new scar
you think you're leaving dawn tyene one
of the sand snakes is a master poisoner
that's her weapon of choice if a single
drop likes contact with the skin yes she
knows many different poisons and many
different ways to administer them he
fight pretty good for a little girl
I hear you studied poisons at the
Citadel I did but a red Viper was
charged famously with poisoning his
weapons you arrive at the capital an
expert in poisoning some days later my
grandson dies of poisoning rather
suspicious why haven't you thrown me in
a dungeon we find out later that he did
poisonous be used to fight the mountain
so even though the mountain kills him
the mountain is in the process of dying
before he even gets around to that the
cause appears to be Manticore venom it
is the deaths head Manticore bloody
Morton's Oberyn has given him a very
potent and painful and slow-acting
poison you can save him stand a chance
any man who calls a poison a woman's
weapon is a traitor to his fellow men
a dagger arrow axe these are the arms of
passion but poison is called calculating
poison is the thought that wakes you in
the morning and lulls you to sleep at
night
you watch your victim die a thousand
times before you ever offer him that
fateful taste he's a man's age so
inferior to a woman's that we are to be
denied such a weapon when I was a boy of
16 a great Lord caught me with his
mistress he should have been honored
instead the fat old fool challenged me
to a duel thanks to my age and status
only to first blood but his mistress and
his wife warned me which of my parts he
intended to draw first blood from he was
strong and fierce but slow I cut him
quickly and the duel ended with honor
satisfied then his wounds festered and
he died
ever since men have called me the red
Viper a name that never fails to draw a
laugh from me as if a single serpent was
online your venom essence of nightshade
is the gentlest of poisons a drop
dissolved into wine will slow a pounding
heart and stop a hand from shaking three
drops will grant a night of deep and
dreamless sleep ten drops and you will
have a sleep that does not end basilisk
blood it will give cooked meat a savory
smell but if eaten it produces violent
madness in beasts as well as men a mouse
will attack a lion aftertaste of
basilisk blood but to a man who knows
his art is not passion a form of madness
widows blood forces a man's bladder and
bowels to fail he drowns in his own
poisons a slow and painful death it has
earned its name many times I am sure the
tears of lys a rare and costly poison
clear tasteless and odorless dissolved
in wine or water it eats at a man's
bowels he dies in agony which will not
appear unusual if the victim is old or
sickly a favorite tool of impatient
errors across the world on certain
islands of the Jade Sea grows a certain
plant the leaves must be aged and soaked
in a wash of limes sugar water and
certain rare spices from the Summer
Isles afterward the potion must be
thickened with ash and allowed to
crystallize the process is slow and
difficult the necessaries costly and
hard to acquire the alchemists of lys
know the way of it and the faceless men
of Braavos and the maesters dissolved in
wine it makes the muscles of a man's
throat clench tighter than any fist a
victim's face turns as purple as the
little crystal seed from which his death
was grown and so we call it the
strangler which of these files would I
take from its shelf you may ask none to
kill a man at his table or in his bed
bores me to toil hours over a boiling
pot measuring and stirring bores me how
life begins is always entertaining and
my kind must make sure its end is worth
our weight